not surprisingly former vice president  mike pence is a complete and total  hypocrite back when it was hillary  clinton he praised the fbi for reopening  an investigation into hillary clinton's  personal email server even though it had  been investigated even though we  resolved every question that we had  about it and yet now after the search  warrant was served  executed at trump's mar-a-lago house  mike pence tweets that he's concerned  about the unprecedented search of the  residents of trump and that no former  president has been subject to such a  raid the unprecedented thing it's bs  trump did things no former president has  done  and so it would make sense that things  that have never happened before happen  everything that has ever happened at  some point happened for the first time  and this is the first time for a search  warrant at the personal residence of a  former president